[Applause]
happy thursday everyone oh it's a big
day here at fox news it's our 25th
anniversary
yes
all right
25 years ago this network was launched
and joe biden had just turned 69.
you know 25 years now normally if
something's over 25 it's too old for me
but so much has happened in that time
this was me 25 years ago
and this is me now
that's what you get from taking care of
yourself cat
not a drop of that virgin's blood went
to waste
meanwhile you know here's cat 25 years
ago
and now here's her today but without
makeup
yeah thank god for our amazing hair and
makeup team
by the way emily compagno is here
tonight
there's emily from 25 years ago
oh wow
you've changed but i totally support the
transition and the decision
so what was it like back when we we
started well unlike mainstream media we
weren't afraid to take chances mainly
because fnc didn't drug test us back
then
here's our first morning show called
marshmallow and friends
[Applause]
hard to believe that did not win a
daytime emmy
i remember ducey having to give kill me
the heimlich because he started choking
on one of those little buggers
their ratings plunged when kilmead
survived
we also created hard-hitting prime time
programming like the slap factor
our motto back then was we slap you
decide how hard
it's also written in lipstick on the
mirror above my waterbed
that's two groans but people also came
to fox for the personalities unlike
places like cnn where hapless drones
regurgitated words from a teleprompter i
mean look at this bunch you'd find more
charisma on a coroner's table
but fox created relationships with its
viewers with dynamic likable characters
you probably don't remember this lively
debate show clucko and mergla
very stupid doctor
you should know better than to attack us
but we did not attack silence
they were actually arguing over the iraq
war
[Laughter]
then there's our edgy late night show
let's talk about sax
[Applause]
[Applause]
cavuto has changed a lot
that went on from 11 p.m to 5 a.m with
the stamina on that guy and of course
this was our afternoon chat show called
we eat children
oh
oh hello
i've just been to the toy shop
and you know what i bought should i show
you
here it is
it's a glass puppet
and you know you can do all sorts of
things with a glove puppet and those
things we can't show you
yes we cut out the part where they
actually do eat the children our weekend
show however was called ferris wheel
losers
[Music]
you know that uh that show was the
genesis for outnumbered
[Laughter]
finally we launched our business channel
with ultimate stock tips
yeah he was some kind of host that guy
got me to buy a lot of stock in enron so
we've grown a lot since then well not me
i've actually shrunk
but i don't think there's been a success
story quite like fox coming out of
nowhere mocked by the mainstream and
then beating the hell and the lies out
of all of them
yes
oh
all the other networks love to crap all
over us and then suddenly they all tried
to become us fox news quickly became
number one and made the other networks
of course look like number two
it happened for one reason it wasn't
afraid we had bigger balls than a circus
elephant
fox wasn't trying to fit in with some
media cool kids table if you look at our
competition they were terrified of
upsetting their industry peers which is
what happens when you all play for the
same team fox said screw that there's an
entire country not being served and
we're taking them
i wonder what life would be like without
fox news i mean or or just imagine if
there was only one perspective in other
areas of life
yeah doc so i was throwing the football
around with the kids and my elbow's just
killing me oh man yeah that's for sure
terminal
terminal shouldn't i get a second
opinion sorry pal i'm the only game in
town and i know for a fact you're gonna
die
so i really have no other choices nope
oh and don't worry when you're gone i'll
take good care of your wife easy cuomo
so i got to fox full time 13 years ago
you might remember this classic
hey this is red eye a new show about
politics pop culture and macrame it's
kind of like larry king but without the
dead guy first thing we're going to talk
about this is our first show porn
that's aged well
like a loaf of white bread that felt
behind a refrigerator five years ago
i look disgusting but as odd as that
show was fox stood by it like a nurse
besides a gravely ill patient
of course they put us on at 3am i think
that was the first example of social
distancing
they hit us like a body in the trunk of
a serial killer's car
but they all saw something in me besides
a pint of gin and 25 bar olives they saw
my genius the talent the quads and they
knew i was the man they wanted to see at
3 a.m in the eastern time zone
on tv instead of outside their windows
crouched in the bushes
but i'm grateful to fox it's amazing
they hired me after visiting angels
fired me
[Laughter]
they found that i was stealing bed pants
they make great dinner plates
but but history has a way of repeating
itself the way fox news entered the
arena in clobbered mainstream news
this show now is doing the same thing
with late night the mainstream media
treated us like a joke now we're the
ones delivering the punch lines
and every night millions of you are
laughing along with us the current crop
of stale boring partisan late night
hosts are more interested in having
nancy pelosi write their scripts then
they aren't keeping their audience
interested snl won't even make fun of
joe biden no wonder they had their
lowest rated show in history last week
their season premiere
but this show followed the game plan of
fox news look at what all the sheep are
doing and provide what's missing the
unspeakable truths the humor the fun fox
news also loves its country and for that
fox stood apart from the other media
types who thought it cool to denigrate
the bitter clingers as cnn devolves into
a shrill clown car of sad scolds we
laugh harder than kamala harris after
doing five whippets
as msnbc continues to use the emergency
room at the mental hospital as their
employee pool we hire the renegades
and as late night hosts
shows become just more boring soapbox
soapbox lectures we're reinventing all
of those people will keep watching us
and they will keep reporting what we do
and say and we will continue to gladly
let them and we have you to thank for
this so thanks america and also you're
welcome america
[Applause]
welcome tonight's yes
his parents don't let him stay up this
late and if they find out he's here he's
grounded north carolina gop congressman
madison calthore
she talks so fast auctioneers ask her to
take a breath outnumbered co-host emily
campono
they call his fans iro maniacs mainly
because they like to burn things
co-hosting fox and friends first todd
pyro
and she's a morning person because she's
constantly mourning her mistakes from
the night before fox news contributor
cat tim
all right
todd i have to go to you first because
you were an intern
right at the launch
1998 two years after the launch but
still i mean this place was nothing like
it is today with one exception you are
always allowed to be yourself here and
for somebody like me i'm not allowed to
be myself at home they asked me to
really tone it down but to come here
right you get it so to come here and
actually be yourself is what makes us so
successful what did you do as it who you
who did you interned for uh i interned
on a show called like the edge oh yeah
over that thing the edge uh they had no
idea what they were doing and i feel
like i can say that it was so
unorganized but that's what made it
great because you got an opportunity as
an intern to figure it out and learn do
you remember that it hosts
i remember i once brought john scott a
script john scott all right it might
have been john scott and that was it and
there were a few others a guy named
chris osborne these do like uh the
reports on the weekend yeah and they
would let me write these things and it
was a great opportunity i also got roast
beef sandwiches a lot yeah i remember
both of those experiences but it's the
fact that like the place has changed but
the fundamental nature of it has you're
allowed to be yourself and that's what
makes us great yeah so uh congressman
cawthorn you weren't even born were you
i was not alive at the time no no no no
when did you first start watching fox uh
probably about two days after i was born
it's shocking i mean you
fox news is celebrating 25 years which
is incredible you guys are now
constitutionally eligible to run for
congress
uh but what's incredible is you know cnn
is over there just celebrating having 25
viewers yes
and they're surprisingly all in terminal
b of jfk yeah
very good point no we have to on them
because right now they're
so they let's be clear they are the
losers and all they're doing are like
because we're enjoying this they're
doing these little things bad-mouthing
us saying oh we're bad for america but
it's because they are the losers that's
like you know tom brady here winning the
super bowl and the team saying you're
bad for america does he look like tom
brady
the women are going yeah
yeah
meanwhile i look like greg brady
emily uh you're a relatively new member
of the fox family
was it me that made you want to join
should i be honest uh i think to
piggyback on your point that what always
attracted me to fox through all the
years and through my career development
was the caliber here it was obvious that
the people here and what was being
produced it just was head and shoulders
above every other network above
everything else that was being put out
there and
i felt the same way i feel like i've had
the honor of participating in a lot of
different industries and doing a lot of
different things and nothing really felt
like home i always felt one step out and
yet here i can be totally myself and
provide analysis in certain ways and be
myself here and there's always an
opportunity to shine here right we're
playing football at eight in the morning
on the plaza or we're telling jokes at
11 p.m or we're hitting serious topics
at noon all of that stuff there's room
for all of us here but the common
denominator is the truth and that we
love this country
very good that's great
i only i just wish that maybe you were
less yourself
i'm joking not really but
as i said before this is the time where
we crap all over our rivals that we have
crushed there are no interesting people
on the other networks there are no cat
temps there's not a single cat temp on
on on any of those shows they would
never hire you they would never hire a
tyrus they certainly wouldn't hire me
no they wouldn't um
uh
but you wouldn't want to i mean what
we're doing on this show is crazy and
that's what makes it awesome i think um
i
always wanted to do this i was watching
red eye before you knew i existed and i
waited for a few years to tell you that
yes uh be because it's you can do what
you want you said you can be yourself
and not everybody here is the same
that's what people always think oh fox
news you think this you think this you
think this if you think that you're
going to end up being wrong so there's a
lot of people here with a lot of
different perspectives and it's just
really awesome to work here it is true
because you know
oh
oh and i love the country
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you know what's interesting to me is as
the elites you know and the
pseudo-intellectuals crawl further up
their own butts this
we just become more successful you know
what i mean i find that yeah they're
eating themselves while we're rising
above the rest exactly
they're eating their own butts
[Laughter]
okay i should probably just move on hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else